Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, Bethenny Frankel,
founder of the game‐changing
mega‐brand Skinnygirl,
joins the Tank.
I don't wanna be partners
with someone
who doesn't know
my value.
You came on "Shark Tank." Did
you not expect us to be sharks?
Guys,
we can see you.
[ Laughter ]
Brandon, at the time, was having
his own butt‐wiping issues.
I didn't say it!
I said, "Team building"!
You copied me!
He's a copycat!
♪♪
Oh!         Oh!
Oh!                          Oh!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank are brothers
who turned a game
into a lucrative business.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Sean Bingham.
And I'm Jared Bingham.
We're from Provo, Utah.
And in you hadn't caught on yet,
we're brothers.
We're the founders
of Adventure Hunt,
and we're seeking $150,000 in
exchange for 10% of our company.
Adventure Hunt is a fun
and adventurous
modern‐day treasure hunt.
Can you imagine the thrill
of digging up
an actual
buried treasure chest?
Well, that thrilling experience
is exactly what we offer.
Don't just
take our word for it.
Here's a little taste of
the Adventure Hunt experience.
Adventure Hunt sends you off
in teams of two to four people
on the adventure
of a lifetime ‐‐
an exhilarating,
adrenaline‐packed ride
we promise
you will never forget.
Hmm.
You'll complete
both gut‐bustingly funny
and adventurous challenges
that unlock a real‐life treasure
map on our Adventure Hunt app.
From there, you put your mind
and will to the test
as you solve clues
guiding you to the buried booty.
That's right, and it's
a race to the finish
because the first team
to get to the treasure chest
and dig it up
wins insanely epic prizes,
which includes a luxurious trip
to paradise for the whole team.
Now, Sharks, we know
that with Shark mentorship,
expertise, and capital,
we can turn this treasure
of a company
into something Captain Jack
himself would envy.
We want to show you guys
a quick demonstration today.
We brought with us
two past participants.
So, how it works
is on hunt day,
teams receive
a list of challenges.
Some of the challenges
are adventurous,
and some are
just plain funny.
You tackle
each challenge,
taking photos and videos
along the way,
post them to Instagram
for our team to verify
and unlock
the treasure map.
A good example
of an adventurous challenge
might be
the slackline.
So, Addison,
let's see what you got.
All right, Chloe,
let's do this.
Okay.
Gotta find the treasure.
You ready?
‐Oh, wow.
‐You got this.
Herjavec: Go!
Yes, yes, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right!
Let's go!
Yeah!
The fun points are designed
to just make people laugh.
A fan favorite is
the good old‐fashioned wedgie.
‐A wedgie?
‐Greiner: A wedgie?
Assume the position.
♪♪
[ Herjavec laughs ]
This is for you,
Adventure Hunt.
Oh!         Oh!
Oh!                          Oh!
♪♪
Now, the ‐‐ typically, there's
15 clues you'd have to solve
to get to the actual
buried treasure chest.
There really is a buried
treasure chest in each city,
and there is
one here today.
So, let's see
that final clue.
Addison: "Seek,
and seashell find."
Seek,
and seashell find.
Sea ‐‐ seashell.
‐What could it mean?
‐I think it's here.
‐It's probably under ‐‐
‐Are you filming?
Okay. I'm filming.
Oh, my gosh.
‐I think that's it!
‐It's a buried treasure!
‐Oh, my gosh!
‐Yeah!
We're going to paradise!
[ Both screaming ]
‐Whoo!
‐Yeah!
Two trips to Panama?
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, we ‐‐ we wanna throw it
to you guys for questions now.
But before we do so,
I feel like ‐‐
I feel like maybe I see a couple
of you eyeing the slackline.
Is any of daring ‐‐
‐Yeah, Robert.
Robert.
You ever done
one of these before?
‐No!
‐Okay.
Chloe will give you
a hand.
‐Yeah.
‐Come on!
‐Hard.
‐You think it's hard?
‐Yes.
‐Hold his ‐‐ Hold his hands.
‐You could do it.
‐You got this.
Okay,
just stare at ‐‐
If you stare at the end point,
it helps a lot.
‐Yeah.
‐Stare at the end.
[ Laughter ]
Stare at the end.
Stare at the end!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Guys, what a great
start to the pitch, right?
‐Yes.
‐Thank you. Thank you.
Congrats.
Now, is there a real business?
Do you have sales?
‐Yes, we do.
We've been around
for 18 months,
and so far,
we have $769,000 in sales.
‐Oh.
‐What?
‐Oh, wow.
‐Okay.
‐That's great.
So, this year,
you've done $667,000.
Frankel: But can you just start
from the beginning?
‐Okay.
‐We are sitting home.
‐Yeah.
‐We find you on the Internet.
We ‐‐ We wanna have
a fun adventure.
‐Yep.
‐What goes down?
Okay.
So, yes.
We do a ton of
social‐media advertising.
Instagram and Facebook are
kind of our bread and butter.
So, you see the ad.
You register on our website.
That's where
we collect the money.
‐How much?
‐Okay, and how much is it?
We have three different
registration levels.
The lowest level
is 32 bucks,
and then
the highest level's $99.
The event is the same
for everybody,
but you get different items
when you register.
Frankel: Okay.
How many people do it
in a city at one time?
We averaged 300 this ‐‐
these last 48 events.
Wow.
Honestly, the beauty
of this business
is that the app does
a lot of the work for us, right?
So we don't have
dozens of employees.
In fact, we don't have
any employees on site
the day of the event because
the app has all the clues on it.
So they can start
from home.
They can start
wherever they want.
And then they get
this list of challenges.
They're like, "Okay, we can ‐‐
we can go cliff jumping.
We can go surfing.
We can do this.
We can do that."
Usually, the list
is like 50 items long.
They just have to do
like 10 of them.
‐Wow.
‐You know?
So they pick any 10 they need
to get the points for us
to then unlock the treasure map.
‐All right.
So ‐‐ So Bethenny and I
go do this thing.
We do it,
we send our picture, Instagram.
‐To Instagram.
‐Somebody verifies it.
Yep, and then,
you just are solving clues,
clue to clue
to clue to clue.
So that's
when it gets fun.
Yeah.
What do you need
from a Shark?
Honestly, the biggest thing
we need is a marketing expert
who can come in and help us
see what we're missing.
‐So you want to include ‐‐
‐I know what you're missing.
You need to have this be
a travel ‐‐ a travel experience.
You need to make everything more
thematic and not just geared
to, like, you know,
gear‐head adventure guys.
You need wild‐girls'‐night‐out
type of things.
Yes.
‐Like, you need ‐‐
‐We do need that.
‐And you need ‐‐
‐Well, maybe not.
Cuban:
If you're single, right?
‐Yeah. He's married. I'm single.
‐Yeah.
‐You could date Bethenny.
We have so much in common.
‐Wait.
What do we have
in common?
Uh, you know,
that we're both single, I guess.
[ Laughter ]
We do.
We have that.
You smoothie!
‐Wow.
‐All right.
Well, I'm gonna
make an offer.
$150,000 for 25%
with a couple of conditions.
So many people are afraid
to try new things.
Yes.
So as part of this,
you kind of make
some of the tasks to be like,
"Send us a video of you
doing something
that you've never done before.
Go try it," you know.
And then, team‐building.
I think you're missing out
on a whole thing
with offices and businesses.
‐Yes.
Good idea. Yeah,
I love the corporate idea.
Frankel: Yeah.
And then, I ‐‐
I really do think you
have to have a dating aspect.
You have to partner
with a match for someone.
We actually have a ton of people
do this as dates,
so that's great.
We have people propose
on this.
Sean,
do you like the offer?
So,
we are very flattered.
We ‐‐ We definitely, out of
respect for the other Sharks
and out of respect
for the business,
I would like to know
if there's anyone else.
I'm simplify, first.
I'm out, guys.
This ‐‐
'Cause of Rugged Maniac.
We do some similar things.
It's not really a fit for us.
‐Okay.
‐Fair enough. Thank you.
‐Well, thank you.
‐‐I'll help you out.
‐Tickity‐tock.
I'll help you out.
Um, I don't like being around a
lot of people.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I love you guys, but I just
don't see this working.
I'm out.
Wow.
Greiner:
I like it.
I think
it sounds very fun.
Um...
♪♪
Lori,
what are you doing?
I ‐‐ I ‐‐
What are you doing?
‐What are you doing?
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Sean and Jared have an offer
on the table from Bethenny
for their experiential
contest company, Adventure Hunt.
But Lori and Robert
may also be interested.
Herjavec: All right.
I love the adventure, but here's
why I'm really excited by it.
I see a huge business
in the, uh, enterprise space,
in the business space ‐‐
large companies
doing team building.
We're doing them all the time.
We're running out of ideas.
I love it.
I love you guys.
$150,000...
for 25%.
‐We keep ‐‐
‐It's the same thing.
‐Yeah.
‐So, identical offers, right?
‐Identical but different.
I would use some of the money to
hire some corporate sales folks.
Yeah, that's what
we wanna do, too.
Go ‐‐ Go hard‐core
into that area.
Greiner: You know,
I was thinking about your space
and the fact that, you know,
you've already
got all these people
that watch all the shows
that do this kind of thing.
Yep.
And they're like,
"Oh, I wish I could do that,
but I can't get on
that TV show."
So you got them the ability to
do it, which I think is genius.
But I think
the two Sharks at the end
would be
better partners for you.
And so, I'm out.
♪♪
Would either of you
come down off 25%?
25% is ‐‐
‐Do you mean like, 24%?
I mean, like, 11%.
‐11%?
‐I would not go down to 11%.
‐But Bethenny ‐‐
‐That's not really ‐‐
I'll do it for 20%,
but right now, no more BS.
Right now, 20%.
Herjavec: You don't wanna go
that direction.
That's it.
$150,000, 20%.
You don't wanna go
that direction.
‐$150,000, 20%.
‐It's not a dating app.
But I didn't say it!
I said team building!
You copied me!
He's a copycat already!
Sean, $150,000, 20%,
I'll do it.
‐15%.
‐I won't do it for 15%.
I'll do it for 20%
right now.
We can get you
in the enterprise space.
I'm stuck at 20%.
♪♪
Bethenny,
what do you think?
I don't wanna be partners with
someone who doesn't my value.
Like, you really should be
taking this deal with me.
[ Laughs ]
I'm really good at marketing,
beyond belief.
I have, um,
incredible ideas.
And I have
an army of women.
You know, when you get the
women, you're gonna get the men.
You're ‐‐
You're a dummy if you don't.
Cuban:
What would you like to do?
You have to decide.
So, we came in
at a $1.5 million valuation.
Do you not think
that's a fair valuation?
You came on "Shark Tank." Did
you not expect us to be sharks?
We did.
I was girl,
broke.
I had an idea
for the first
low‐calorie margarita
ever to be made.
I turned the brand
in 18 months,
broke in studio apartment,
to cover of Forbes magazine.
Who do you want
as a partner?
I know what we can
build this thing into.
That's the excitement
I get.
This is one of the few products
that's fun for the consumer,
but it can go boom
in the enterprise space.
Would you guys
be willing to go...
together?
No.
♪♪
We can see you.
[ Laughter ]
You know, we can see you
standing there!
[ Laughter ]
It's decision time,
guys.
♪♪
All right.
We choose Robert.
‐Yeah!
‐Oh!
‐Oh, again!
‐Whoo!
I tried!
I tried.
We're gonna kill it.
Super excited.
‐Thank you.
We're excited.
‐Yeah, thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐Aw.
‐Hey, thank you, everybody.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Thank you.
No, you're welcome.
Come here.
I feel like ‐‐ I feel like
I'm the one who lost!
Yeah, baby, yeah!
We've just been
on "Shark Tank."
[ Both laugh ]
♪♪
Narrator: In season eight,
we watched Shannon Zappala
and Regan Kelaher
strike a deal with Mark, Lori,
and Robert for their portable
wine glass company, Goverre.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
Zappala: In just the week
after "Shark Tank,"
we had over $400,000 in sales.
We sold out immediately and had
to make an emergency order
just to keep up with demand.
Kelaher: Within a month, we had
to move out of Shannon's garage
into a 1,500‐square‐foot
warehouse.
And even that's
becoming too small.
‐What's happening?
‐Hi!
Cuban: I'm here at Goverre
because I wanted to see
for myself whether
or not their warehouse
could handle their growth.
Obviously, you guys
have done an amazing job.
But if we're gonna go
to $8 million, $15 million,
$20 million,
this is gonna be a bottleneck.
I think I've got a great
solution for you guys.
One of my portfolio companies,
and what they're able to
replicate and scale
all the warehousing functions.
I advise a lot of my
"Shark Tank" companies
to partner with
a fulfillment center
for the simple reason that it's
hard to be good at everything.
You get to concentrate
on what you're good at.
Kelaher: We're still gonna keep
our current warehouse
for specialty orders,
but for our mass retailers,
we're gonna be using Mark's
fulfillment center.
We can now focus on design
and creativity
rather than packing
orders and fulfillment.
‐Let's do it.
‐Let's do it!
I'm ready.
‐All right.
I'm so proud of Shannon
and Regan.
They were able to take a glass,
grow to more than $2 million
in sales in just the last year,
and more importantly,
they're profitable.
They literally are gonna put
into their pockets
more than $473,000.
They've proved to everybody
that with a lot of hard work,
anything is possible.
Zappala: "Shark Tank" has been
a life‐changing experience.
We've turned something we love
into a thriving business,
and we couldn't be more
excited for the future.
All: Goverre!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up are
entrepreneurs with a mission
to help educate children
while making money.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Chid Liberty.
And I'm Adam Butlein.
Better known to
his friends as "Booty."
Our company's called
Uniform.
We are today seeking $300,000
for 10% of the business.
To put it simply,
Uniform is an ethical
clothing company.
But our story goes
so much deeper.
See, Uniform is a street wear
brand on a mission.
We're out to re‐shape
the fashion industry
with minimalist
hip hop‐infused designs
that are 100%
made in Africa.
We have spent years working
with the best producers
in countries like Egypt,
Ghana, and Liberia.
Literally from
dirt to shirt,
we engineer
luxury‐quality staples
like our amazingly
soft T‐shirts
to our best‐selling women's
jumpsuit and bomber jacket.
We provide work for
thousands of working women
in safe factories all throughout
the continent of Africa.
But our mission
goes even deeper,
because with each purchase,
we donate a school uniform
to a student
whose parents could not
otherwise afford one.
You see, all over
the developing world,
kids are required
to wear a uniform
in order to go to school.
So this donated uniform can mean
an entire future for a child.
We call this our
signature +1 program,
because you get amazing clothes,
a child gets a school uniform,
and moms get jobs right
in their local communities.
But let's get
something straight.
Uniform is not a charity.
We are a clothing company
on a mission.
The mission is amazing,
but the clothes are fire.
We brought you
some gifts.
Here you go, Bethenny.
‐Thank you so much.
‐No, thank you.
Did you get her
the jumpsuit?
[ Laughs ] Well ‐‐
‐Thank you.
‐I'll have to find out.
Oh, cool.
‐Oh, that'll work.
‐Yeah.
We thought, perfect for,
uh, sports.
‐Yeah!
‐Yeah, very thoughtful.
A little working out.
I got it.
Yeah, very thoughtful.
Oh, my God.
I was just thinking,
"What am I gonna wear
at the club tonight?"
[ Laughter ]
‐We got you, Robert.
‐Yeah, I know.
‐Except ‐‐ Except...
‐I love it.
‐It looks awesome.
‐...you gave me a 36‐inch waist?
Are you kidding me?
‐Yeah.
‐I love Bethenny's jacket.
‐No, it's amazing.
‐Yeah.
And the coolest thing
about that jacket is
it's actually reversible.
Really?
It was our number‐one seller
at Bloomingdales.
It sold out
on our website.
What does this retail for?
$88.
And you can imagine
at Bloomingdales,
it's next to brands
where the bombers are
between $250 and $500.
Tell us your
last year in sales.
Okay. So, we did $400,000
on Kickstarter.
Then last year,
we only did $300,000,
but it's because we
launched at Bloomingdales
for back‐to‐school,
and then online,
our website launched in,
uh, November.
So we didn't have much year
to generate sales.
Right. Now, what percentage of
those were online, and what ‐‐
what was retail?
Probably about 70% retail,
30% online.
So, what's your history, uh,
you know, before this?
Were you already
in the textile or fashion?
Yeah. We started a company in
2010 called Liberty & Justice,
that was only a manufacturing
company in Africa.
I'm from Liberia.
Sure.
I was interested in providing
jobs, uh, to ‐‐
to women after the war.
Adam is my best friend.
We do everything together.
He's a Jewish boy from
Milwaukee, but he's like,
"Bro, I am coming with you."
We went to Africa.
We established the first
fair‐trade certified factory
on the continent.
We ended up getting about
$40 million in annual orders.
‐Wow.
‐It was a pretty amazing time
for the business...
And?
...as you can imagine.
Um, and then in 2014,
this little thing called
the Ebola Outbreak
happened...
‐Ooh.
‐...and completely shut down
our company.
Wow.
We went from figuring out how
quickly we could grow
to how to save all
of our workers' lives.
You couldn't go to work.
You couldn't go to school.
So, we're getting
ready to ship,
and the entire town
turns into a ghost town.
And so what happened after
it was all cleared up?
So, nine months later,
we go back on the ground.
Nine months?
It took nine months
to get no new cases
of Ebola in Liberia.
Um, all of our customers
are long‐gone.
They kind of were like,
"Hey, we gave you guys a shot.
We spent two years building
this thing with you,
and nothing happened."
So we essentially went
back to the factory,
met with the workers.
We had th‐‐ hundreds of
thousands of dollars of fabric
that was just sitting in
a warehouse for nine months.
And we were trying to figure out
what we could do
with this fabric, and it finally
dawned on somebody
that we should make
school uniforms.
MIT did research and proved
that if you give
a child a school uniform,
their attendance
goes up by up to 62%.
And for every three young girls
you give a uniform to,
two will delay
their first pregnancy.
That's major.
And so I just thought,
"My goodness, what if
we could give,
uh, these
uniforms away?"
And I thought, "Huh,
I have seen this model
before where you sell something
and you give something away.
What if we launched
a T‐shirt company
that turned into a full‐clothing
company to pay for it?"
And that's how
Uniform was born.
What are you
looking for from us?
So, we really are looking
for partners in the business
that help us take it
to the next level.
Next year, we're scheduling
to launch at Target, actually.
It's a huge deal.
So going from 13 stores
to 1,300 stores,
potentially.
‐That's committed?
‐It's committed.
Just with kids.
We don't have
the purchase orders yet,
but we've having meetings.
Kids ‐‐ Kids' clothing?
Yeah.
Oh.
Just kids.
Listen. It looks like
in all areas,
you are kind of covered, right?
What do you really think that
we can do for you besides money?
Daymond, I don't know anybody
who would want to start
a street wear brand and not be
partners with Daymond John.
Lori, take them on QVC.
I think they would be
absolutely gigantic.
Mark, there's so much that
we can do with the NBA.
Bethenny,
I mean, legendary.
I think there's a million
things that we can do
in terms
of capsule collections.
And, Robert, we've seen what
you've done with other
apparel brands,
um, on the Tank.
So, along that line,
I appreciate that.
‐Dude, you're a great sales guy.
‐Thank you.
I mean, you're just
bam, bam, bam.
Okay, let me
tell you a story.
So, nine years ago,
somebody came on the show
and they had a T‐shirt.
It was a simple T‐shirt,
and I was like,
"I love it,
I'm gonna invest in it."
Daymond was at
the other end going,
"He doesn't know
what he's doing."
‐Oh, my God.
‐And we got into it.
We thought we were gonna
sell everything,
and then it was like
inventory and this,
and we have to buy now
for a season eight months later.
‐Sure.
‐Blew my mind.
‐Yes.
‐Great presentation.
Bootie, thanks for being...
Thanks.
...whatever it is you do.
Yeah. I'm out.
Thank you, Robert.
Greiner: So, Mark and I
invested in a company
a few years ago called Umano.
They also were in Bloomingdales,
there also was
a lot of T‐shirts.
Um, we thought they were cool.
They looked nice.
The fabric was good
and all of that.
But before we could even close
the deal, they went bankrupt.
And Mark and I
looked at each other
and we were like,
"Wow," you know?
‐That was fast.
‐Yeah.
And what it taught me is
that the clothing business
is really competitive.
It's really tough.
‐Yeah.
‐So I ‐‐
I don't think it's
the right investment for me.
So I wish you luck, but I'm out.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you so much, Lori.
So, I was you when I had
my idea for my cocktail.
And I went to somebody
who had worked
in the liquor business
for years,
because I knew
what I didn't know.
I've always been good
at knowing what I don't know.
You don't want to go with me
because I'm not an expert.
It'll be the blind
leading the deaf.
I'm out.
‐So, I'm all in...
‐Yeah.
...when it comes
to the mission, right,
because when you lift up outside
the world, the world gets safer.
The world gets better.
Right.
I'll simplify things, guys.
I don't know ‐‐ you know,
everybody says,
"Oh, that's nice."
But I have no clue, right?
I don't think I could ‐‐
I could do anything there,
so I have to say
for those reasons,
I'm out, guys.
All right.
Thank you, Mark.
John: So, guys, I invested in
a company named Bombas.
And for every pair of socks
that they sell,
they donate a pair
to the homeless.
And it taught me a lot.
It taught me that, number one,
they stayed
laser‐focused online.
They've given away almost four
million pairs of socks, right?
‐Yeah.
‐So I value what you're doing.
But it actually made me re‐think
my own core business,
because I started to realize
that going into retail
creates a massive
amount of inventory,
you get half the price for it.
You don't even know
who purchased it.
You can't up‐sell the customer.
That's what
I'm wrestling with.
‐Yeah.
‐Mm‐hmm.
On the flip side, you're giving
jobs to, uh, women in Africa.
I had the honor of going
over to Kenya with, uh,
President Obama, and, you know,
he made a really great speech
that women at a certain time
weren't able
to even work, right?
Yeah.
And he said
to the whole country,
"How can you ever win a game
if 50% of your players
can't even get on the field?"
‐Right.
‐Exactly.
I think that's amazing, um,
so I'm ‐‐ I'm torn.
♪♪
So, guys, my number will be
available to you for mentoring.
But I just don't think that
I can help you in this instance,
so I'm out.
‐Oh.
‐Oh, my.
I wanted him
to be in!
I wanted him to be in, too.
I wish I was ‐‐
I was wrestling with it
as I was talking about it,
but I just ‐‐ I've worked
so hard to try
to change my business.
No, no. It's tough, man.
I've learned that from you.
It's very hard.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐All the best.
‐Appreciate it.
‐All right.
Liberty: When people
think about Liberia,
they think about the civil war
and they think about Ebola.
Now they can talk about Uniform.
Now they can talk about a story
that is so amazingly powerful
and a business that is
literally changing the world.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product
that aids something
we all have in common.
♪♪
Hi.
I'm Jessica.
And I'm Brandon.
We live in Dallas,
Texas, and we're...
Cuban: What?
[ Laughter ]
...seeking $50,000...
‐Dallas.
‐...for 20% of our company.
Sharks, we know something
very personal about
each one of you.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Ooh.
You have wiped your butts
with either toilet paper
or wet wipes.
Over the centuries,
we have found very creative ways
to wipe, including stones,
corn cobs,
and even
the "Farmer's Almanac,"
‐Mm.
‐Today, the multi‐billion‐dollar
butt‐wiping industry
has settled on two options ‐‐
toilet paper
and wet wipes.
But dry toilet paper is not
taking care of business.
And wet wipes don't work
for everyone.
Harsh chemicals and synthetic
fibers in some wipe brands
can irritate the skin.
And I found out the hard way
that some of those
"flushable" wipes
aren't so flushable.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐So we created a third option ‐‐
Pristine Cleansing Sprays,
the #1 spray
to wipe your #2 away.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐For adults and kids,
Pristine is sprayed
directly on to toilet paper
so that it
actually cleanses,
and it's
actually flushable.
Pristine is fantastic
for diaper changing, too,
by spraying it directly
on to those dirty little bottoms
or on to cloth
or dry wipes.
Sharks,
we envision a world
where Pristine is to the butt
as shampoo is to hair...
[ Laughter ]
...where the butt is given
the same respect
as the rest of the human body.
I love you guys.
So, are you Sharks ready
to join the "movement"?
‐Oh, my.
‐All right.
We want to pass you
samples out, first.
Bring 'em, come on.
So, we recommend
a double‐fold.
‐Daymond.
‐You have a folding technique.
Fold it twice.
And about three to five sprays
is wh‐‐ is what we recommend.
‐Double‐fold?
‐Yes.
‐You're now free to spray.
‐So it doesn't matter.
You could double, triple,
whatever‐fold,
as long as it's not
single, right?
Yes.
John: Okay, so tell me the story
of how you came up with this.
So, I'm a mom
of three kids.
At ‐‐ at one point,
that means
I wiped four butts
on a daily basis.
Wow.
And I had a young
daughter in diapers
who was severely irritated
by every brand of wipes.
I had a ‐‐ a son who had
a totally different problem.
He was learning
to use the potty.
I gave him some wet wipes,
but he was flushing them.
‐Butt?
‐Butt...
he was flushing them.
And my toilet exploded.
My yard was flooded.
‐Oh.
‐Ow!
‐So I gathered all the wipes,
got 'em out of the house.
‐And how did you meet Brandon?
‐We are first cousins.
‐Interestingly...
‐Uh‐huh.
...Brandon, at the time,
was having his own
butt‐wiping issues...
‐Ooh.
‐Tell us about it, Brandon!
...that I'm sure
he's anxious to tell you about.
That came up at the family
dinner, the Thanksgiving dinner?
You nailed it.
I was a secret wet‐wipe user
for my whole life.
And I eventually developed
a skin allergy.
So it was around this time
that I went over
to Jessica's house
at dinner,
and we ‐‐
you know, butts came up.
They ‐‐ They normally do
at our family dinners.
And we realized that
my problem and the problems
that she was having
with her kids could be solved
by one simple solution.
And then, Pristine was
born at that dinner.
Well, I'm curious.
You know, you came in asking
for $50,000 for 20%.
It's not a big number.
Um...
‐Not bad.
‐...what are your sales?
So, year to date, we have
about $11,000 in sales.
How did you sell the $11,000?
Just curious.
‐Amazon.
‐Amazon? Okay.
‐And, um ‐‐
‐How much does it cost
to produce a bottle,
and how much do you sell it for?
We make it for $1.50.
That's expensive.
It's wholesaled
at about $3.50,
and it's retailed for $7.00.
Is there any competition?
Yes. There are other
adult toilet paper sprays,
about 10, that are sold...
10 of them?
‐Yes.
‐Really?
...that are sold on Amazon.
We have tested and tried them,
and looked at the ingredients.
Red #5, on your rear?
Herjavec:
Jessica, I'm just curious.
Normally, people ask
for too much money.
Why $50,000?
We've valued the company
based on our sales numbers.
‐That's fair, yeah.
‐And we have something
that we would, um,
like to use that money for.
But our big purpose here is,
we know that we need your help.
Well, what would you
like to use it for?
Yeah.
What is the $50,000 for?
We would like
to introduce something,
uh, that is new to
the diaper‐changing world.
‐Okay.
‐It's an automatic,
no‐touch sprayer that can be
used with cloth or dry wipes.
‐What do you mean, no‐touch?
‐So you're saying, like,
the automatic
soap pumps and that,
that you're gonna put
your formula in it.
And then when a mom
is changing the diaper,
she just holds
the paper in front.
It automatically sprays,
and then she wipes.
‐Precisely.
‐So, you're gonna make
a new machine.
No, we know where our
core competency is,
and it's not in
creating a new machine.
We would buy something and sell
it under our Pristine label.
Look, I think
a certain percentage
of people will buy it.
But the challenge for me
is not the product or you guys.
It's the marketing.
You have to convince
people to use it.
Then you have to convince me
of a better product.
I see the marketing challenge
as really almost insurmountable.
It's not for me.
I'm out.
Thank you very much for your
input and for you time today.
‐Thank you, Robert.
‐Guys, I'm a big fanny
of your product.
[ Laughter ]
That's so stupid.
I love it.
Anyways, you know, with
DUDE Wipes, I think
there'd be some ‐‐
some conflict.
And it might make it difficult
for me to work with both.
So for those reasons, I'm out.
‐Thank you, Mark.
We're disappointed
to hear that, and ‐‐
Frankel: I really like you both.
I think you guys are amazing.
But I think that this looks
like hand sanitizer.
If you're going there,
you got to go all the way.
Calling it "Pristine" ‐‐
It could be a jewelry cleaner,
it could be, you know,
a lot of different things.
I really do like you guys.
I just think you are too early
in the process, and I'm out.
‐Thank you, Bethenny.
John: You know, here's what
I have to say, guys.
There's a lot of competition
in this space,
and it's a sensitive topic
and people don't want to
talk about it.
I'm out.
‐Thank you, Daymond.
And then,
there's Lori.
You know, everyone laughed when
I invested in Squatty Potty.
‐Yeah.
‐Everybody laughed.
Squa‐‐ It's huge.
And, you know,
look what happened.
I mean, we literally
have surpassed $100 million
in retail sales.
‐It's amazing.
‐Wow.
So I'm sitting here
trying to think to myself,
you know, would you fit
within their arena?
The problem is, is I don't know
if they're already working
on something like this or not.
So if I were to
give you an offer,
it would be contingent on them
wanting to pick up your product.
So, I'll give you
the $50,000 at 25%.
And if Squatty Potty's
already working on this,
then it won't work.
But if they're not,
you got a deal.
So, would it ‐‐ would it be
something that Squatty Potty
sells as Pristine,
or are they ‐‐ with that label?
No. They would bring it
in under their brand.
They would have to.
But let me tell you
something, you guys.
Squatty Potty has done
$100 million in retail sales
in just a few years.
If you have an opportunity to go
with someone that's already big
and can blow up your product,
and you're just brand‐new,
why wouldn't you?
We want you
as a full partner,
without
the contingency, but ‐‐
‐But the deal is ‐‐
‐The deal's with
‐the contingency.
‐The deal that's offered
is the deal that's offered.
What are you gonna do?
Okay. Lori, we're ‐‐
we're with you.
You got
a contingent deal.
‐It will probably happen.
‐I hope so.
Listen, there's not a lot of
innovation in the toilet space.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations, guys.
Congratulations.
♪♪
Jessica: A potential, uh,
partnership with Squatty Potty
would be beneficial
for both of us.
I really firmly believe that.
They're trying to
help people poop,
and we're trying to clean it.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a product
designed for Man's best friend.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Daniel Lentz.
This is Tom Zipprian,
and we're here from
San Jose, California
to present Aquapaw.
We're seeking $200,000
of investment in exchange
for 7.5% of our company.
Now, imagine you're
beautiful Claire here.
You go out for a nice hike.
You're running
and stomping and rolling
in everything imaginable.
You get home. You see your
favorite person in the world,
and they take one look
at you and say, "Whoa!
You're not coming in the house
looking like that.
You're a mess!"
So they grab you by the collar,
take you out back,
and blast you down with
ice‐cold water from the hose.
Oh, the betrayal.
No wonder they hate it.
And this is what we do
to our pets every time
we try to bathe them.
Well, we have designed
a revolutionary pet‐bathing tool
that not only makes
multitasking easier for you,
but it also makes bath time
easier on your pet.
And it's called
the Aquapaw Bathing Tool.
Our combination sprayer/scrubber
attaches securely to the hand
with a one‐size‐fits‐all
strap.
It's slim and flexible,
giving the use of both hands
to control your dog.
And here's the best part.
You can control the flow
of water with a button
in the palm of your hand.
So, let's see it
in action.
So, first off, notice
how water sprayed
from the tips
of rubber knobs.
And for that reason,
it's injected deep
into the denseness
of fur.
And then once you have
soap on your pet,
it's also a scrubber.
And the Aquapaw integrates
nicely into any household.
Every unit comes
with adaptors
for both the garden hose
and the shower,
making it easier for you
to save time, reduce the mess,
and eliminate the stress
involved with bath time
for both you and your pet.
So, what do you say?
Together: Who wants to
clean up with Aquapaw?
[ Chuckles ]
Well, can we try it
on a real dog?
Together: Absolutely.
[ Laughs ]
So, I've got some samples
for you guys.
And then afterwards,
you're welcome to come up
and try it out.
I've licked a cat
on the show.
I'll bathe a dog.
‐Oh.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I'll do it.
‐Let's do it.
You can take one of each,
if you want.
‐Hi, baby.
‐This is Claire.
‐Aw.
‐Hi, Claire.
‐Thank you.
‐Look at you.
Come on, let's go bathe.
Come on.
You're gonna pull
this strap tight.
‐Okay, okay.
‐And then you're gonna reach in.
There's gonna be a click,
and then it's gonna turn on.
There you go.
‐Is it too cold for her?
‐No, that's good.
‐Oh.
‐Yeah.
‐Hi, baby!
Greiner: She's the sweetest dog.
Frankel: And then turn it off
with your hand, Robert.
Let me see how it turns off.
So, press it
all the way down.
‐That's pretty cool.
‐It's cool.
And then, the shake!
Nice.
There it is.
‐All right, Claire.
‐Here you go, baby.
‐Good girl.
‐Cute.
It's cool.
It's real easy to use.
Frankel: What are your
retail costs?
How much is it?
$24.99.
‐$24.99, okay.
‐Wow.
‐That's a good price.
‐That's cheap.
Yeah. Where are you
selling these now?
Uh, right now we're selling
direct to consumer
through our website,
and then, we also have
a retail partner
called UncommonGoods.
Oh, I know UncommonGoods.
What are selling
to wholesale for?
$12.50.
$12.50, and what does it
cost you to make?
‐$5.25.
‐That's good.
How much lower can you get it?
We think easily,
we could get down to $4.50.
‐Okay.
‐What are your sales?
Uh, in the last year,
we did a Kickstarter.
It was
a successful campaign.
We've been taking preorders
for the past nine months.
And how much
was your goal, and ‐‐
Our campaign was $42,000,
and we hit our goal.
Have you done
any other sales?
Uh, we sold about 200k.
Frankel: Have you
talked to Petco?
We've spoken to Petco.
We've spoken to PetSmart.
We've spoken
to a lot of big guys,
and feedback was great.
I think right now,
they're sort of waiting to see,
'cause we've just
started delivering.
Herjavec: And why is it
worth $3 million?
You're asking $200,000
for 7.5%.
Yeah.
That's a great question.
Um, I mean, up to this point,
200k in sales...
Well, it depends
on the answer.
...200k in sales
in eight months.
That has been with
no advertising at all
and with only one
modestly‐sized retailer.
Next year, we're gonna
dump money into advertising.
We're gonna blow up
our Facebook sales.
We're gonna expand,
hopefully pick up
another two
or three retail partners.
John: Why do you have it ‐‐
But, why are you giving us
the valuation of
"hopefully, if everything
goes perfect"?
Uh, you may get to a point
when you manufacture
and get knocked off.
Your ‐‐ you know, your prices
may be compressioned...
‐Ah, yes.
‐...or ‐‐ and/or diverted.
You mentioned about
it getting knocked off.
We have filed a utility patent.
It's currently under review.
And we've filed a P. C. T.
Lentz: I'd like to say
a couple more things.
I think somebody could see the
brand, they can see the product,
and they can see
the potential to create
a whole ecosystem
of items, right?
Well, okay.
So, expand on the ecosystem.
Yeah.
Well, we have great ‐‐
uh, a lot of great ideas
on how to do it,
but you incorporate
soap dispensation
into the product.
Then also, there's smaller,
low‐hanging fruit
like strainers,
tethers, towels.
I have a question. I've seen
things out there that...
‐You have?
‐Combs, yeah.
...that are scrubbers
with, you know,
water that comes through,
brushes with water.
Okay. So, it ‐‐ they're a lot
of different people
in this category,
but there's no mechanism
where you can actually turn it
on and off with one hand.
I think that's the big...
That is cool.
...the big point
that separates us,
is because you never
have to reach for anything.
So, no one else came out with
an on‐off toggle on the hand?
No. No. There's nothing
like this out there.
You know, it's a great lesson.
Sometimes, the simplest remixes.
I always say that, yeah.
How will you get
that message across
in the three seconds somebody
has to look at this?
Frankel: I got it, though.
I usually never get it.
When I sat here,
I got the whole thing.
There's a button in the middle.
And to me, it makes some sense.
Cuban: And they've got
the hand right there.
And you need more dog
on that packaging.
Lentz: Absolutely.
All right, guys.
Let me start.
I ‐‐ I have a lot of investment
in the pet industry.
We've learned a lot
in the last few years.
Love dogs, but I cannot
get to the $3 million.
I'll give you
the $200,000 for 25%.
That's the level that I see
in terms of the risk
in order to get to market and
the work that it's gonna take.
That's the offer from me.
Thanks, Robert.
I really appreciate it.
‐Thank you.
‐We're gonna consider it.
Okay. So, I feel like this
is a very crowded space.
I kind of like when things are
a little bit more unique.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
‐Oh, that's unfortunate.
‐Sorry to hear that, Lori.
‐Sorry.
‐Guys, I'll be brutally candid.
I hate the pet‐accessory
business.
There's always an idea.
There's always
somebody else to do it.
I think what you've done
is phenomenal,
but somebody's gonna come up
with something
a little bit better,
somehow, someway.
That's just the nature
of the pet‐accessory business.
So for those reasons, I'm out.
‐Thanks, Mark.
Greiner: You haven't heard
from Daymond, who...
Yeah. We've love to hear
your feedback, Daymond.
...actually is Mr. Petco.
[ Laughs ]
John: Yeah, I'm on the ‐‐
I'm on the board
for the Petco foundation.
And Mark brings up
a good point, you know.
The pet industry is really
a challenging industry
for a couple of reasons.
People are habitual.
They'll spend anything
on their pet.
But, you know, it's getting
them educated
that something like this exists
is extremely, extremely hard.
So to value your company
at that much is ‐‐
it's challenging for me to ‐‐
for me to go help you.
I don't want to insult you,
but I know the amount
of work this is gonna be.
I will give you
the $200,000 for 30%.
Ooh! You're going
the wrong way.
‐Well, no.
‐You're not shy.
‐I'm up.
‐Okay.
Uh, okay. I have two dogs,
Biggie and Smalls...
‐Aw.
‐...that are from
the same litter,
but they're 10 pounds apart.
So I'm a very big dog person.
That was a great story.
And I ‐‐ Thank you, good.
Is there an offer
coming or anything?
So I've been ‐‐ No.
Oh, I'm glad you're ‐‐
I'm here to entertain you.
‐Moving on.
‐Listen.
Oh, move on?
I listen to you drone on
for hours.
‐Right.
‐So it's my turn, sunshine.
‐Talk to the hand.
‐Hi.
When you're about to go
offer them a little money,
you can take a little longer.
$200,000 for 30%, but I will
be involved, you know,
with my face in ‐‐
in the advertising.
And it would be contingent
that Biggie and Smalls
have to be on
the package themselves.
I think we could
accommodate that. Okay.
So, three offers,
that's awesome.
Now that the other
offers are at 30%,
I'm gonna go the other way, too.
Just to make it even.
You didn't
take my offer right away.
‐It's all the same offer.
‐I'll do the $200,000
at 30%, also.
‐Ooh!
So, guys, you have three
offers that are identical.
You can counter.
You can say yes or no.
What would you like to do?
Hmm.
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Tom and Daniel have the same
offer from Robert,
Bethenny, and Daymond ‐‐
$200,000 for 30%
of their business, Aquapaw.
Um, I will say the equity
asked is a little high.
Daymond mentioned all
of his Petco experience.
Uh, Bethenny, Robert,
do you guys have any sort of,
uh, connections
with retailers
that you can expedite
this process for us?
‐Oh.
‐Actually, hang on a sec, Tom.
I'm gonna go get my résumé,
and maybe you can have
a look at it!
Frankel: You could've done
research ahead of time.
What are you talking about?
‐You probably want that. ‐Yeah.
I mean, I'm in Kroger, Amazon...
‐Come on.
‐...on Jet, we're all, you know.
Nine seasons, we've sold
a lot of pet stuff.
All right, here's what
I have to say,
and maybe this can help you.
I do have a lot of connections
and experience there.
But to be very honest,
I wouldn't be a spokesperson.
I'd be the back office.
I'd be the one who talks to the
buyers and help you get there.
But if you believe
that you have an offer
by somebody here
who will save you thousands
or maybe millions
of dollars‐worth
of advertising and exposure,
and that's what you need,
I'm not gonna be selfish
and tell you that
I'm gonna do that.
I run a pretty big
cybersecurity business.
I have a full‐time job.
We're here ‐‐
Oh, now all of a sudden,
I'm some schlepper?
We're here to help you.
Oh, I ‐‐ I ‐‐
No, no, no.
If Bethenny has the time to go
on sales calls with you ‐‐
No, I'm not going
on sales calls!
I'm gonna be the girl washing
the dog in that ‐‐ in that...
She'll take some pictures.
I'm not going on
sales calls.
She wants you to use
her face and image...
‐Yeah.
‐...on it, which ‐‐
Which is worth a lot of
money, that I will say.
So, guys, we believe
that all of you
offer value
of different sorts.
Um, we'd like to counter
to see if maybe,
Bethenny, with your connections
on social media,
and Daymond, with your
back‐office
and Petco experience,
you guys consider joining up.
$200,000 for 20%, so $100,000
for 10% and $100,000 for 10%.
Whoa, dude.
If you're getting th‐‐
If you're getting both of us...
Wow!
...I can't even speak
for Daymond yet,
but if you're getting
both of us, definitely the 30%
is not off the table for me.
‐Yeah.
‐So, am I wrong?
I thought you were gonna say
that we were gonna get 60%.
‐Yeah.
‐I mean ‐‐
Tom, listen. I'm out.
You didn't include
me in that.
Aww.
I get it.
And you're the prettiest
one of all of us.
I don't want to be pretty.
I just like being rich, so.
Okay.
I'm out.
Well, I'd like to be both.
Sorry to hear that, Robert.
Thanks, Robert.
So, Daniel and Tom, things are
going in the wrong direction.
What would you like to do?
Herjavec: Yeah.
That wasn't a great counter.
I just got to
point that out.
I just don't think
that works at this moment.
Oh, it's so sad.
You had an offer of 25%.
‐Well, you guys...
‐And you waited.
...what are you gonna do?
Uh, I think we would ‐‐
we would counter
and say, Daymond, would you
come down to $200,000 for 20%?
Now I'm out.
Sorry to hear that,
Bethenny.
Daymond?
30% is my
final offer, guys.
Wow.
[ Sighs ]
Would you be willing to come
down at all to meet us?
That was my final offer.
♪♪
Okay, Daymond, I'm sorry to say
we cannot accept that offer.
Okay. Well, um, I wish
you all the best, guys.
‐All the best, guys.
‐Good product.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate your time, guys.
‐Good luck.
‐Take care.
Good for you for
standing your ground, guys.
Zipprian: We absolutely wanted
Daymond to be our partner.
But 30%, that's ‐‐
that's just too much.
That's more than we're willing
to part with at this time.
I loved
Bethenny's deal.
I would've ‐‐ I ‐‐
I loved my deal, too.
I'd have done that deal
in a second.
‐I would've taken your deal.
‐Okay.
Look, to their credit,
they thought their future
had a lot less risk than we did.
And they're confident in it.
‐Understood.
‐You know what?
They're product innovators,
but truthfully,
there's others
out there like this.
Oh, yeah.
♪♪